well people who have been waiting for
months for unemployment benefits say
they just had enough
today joe moeller talked to a man who
has been waiting since
june and has lost nearly everything he's
live just outside the deter office with
his story tonight here at five joe
yeah we have shared the frustrations of
people for months now
many say the waiting is starting to
destroy their life now i'm personally
contacted just about every single day
from
from someone who's still waiting for
benefits and now many of them are just
so desperate for answers today
we caught up with roger maddox jr to
share his story he says
he lost his job in june and filed for
regular unemployment insurance since
then he
lost his home and much more he uses
phones from family and friends to call
dieter but he says the lines are
always full he says when he does get
through they tell him he has to wait for
an adjudicator to call him back and he
is still waiting
he doesn't have a phone number so he
doesn't know how he'll get a call back
there are many others out there just
like him
i call them every day though like every
single day you know i wake up at
7 30 every morning and then at 7
58 i'm on the phone calling them
sometimes the queue is already full
what do we do now now that the damage is
already done
and continuously happening
what do we do now where are we
i did reach out to dieter to see what
update we could get when it comes to the
backlog of claims we also wanted to know
if there was any sort of update when it
comes to appeals
many people have been wondering when the
appeals process will start because
they are too waiting to have their claim
looked at over again
according to a popular unemployment
facebook page the appeals date
keeps changing now hopefully we'll get
some sort of update from dieter and when
we do hear that
we'll be sure to pass along but just to
give you another idea of how
these frustrations continue i just spoke
to a man who's out here who pulled up
here
trying to get some sort of answers just
arriving here maybe
to see if he could talk to just somebody
here at the dead or office but of course
this office is
closed reporting live in las vegas joe
muller 8 news